bonjour
il va pas
du pragmatisme de william james james
est un philosophe et psychologue
américain de la deuxième moitié du 19e
et du début du 20e siècle et il est l'un
des représentants de cette école
philosophique qu'on appelle le
pragmatisme les deux autres principaux
représentants de cette école étant
charles sanders perth et john du oui si
je fais cette précision c'est parce
qu'il existe des désaccords il existe
des dissensions entre ses trois
théoricien du pragmatisme et aujourd'hui
on va s'intéresser spécifiquement au
pragmatisme tels que théorisée par
william james et si j'ai fait ce choix
c'est parce que james nous a proposé une
présentation de cette école
philosophique une présentation destinée
au grand public à travers son livre
principal qui est un recueil de huit
conférences et qui s'intitule
précisément le pragmatisme
alors avant de commencer je dois vous
dire quelque chose ce que vous allez
entendre dans cet audio va vous paraître
très étrange
et quand je dis que ça va vous paraître
étrange je ne veux pas dire par là que
vous n'allez pas comprendre
je veux dire par là que ça va vous
paraître extrêmement éloignée de ce que
vous avez l'habitude d'entendre en
philosophie
il est fort possible que vous ressortiez
de cet audio avec l'impression que ce
dont on aura parlé n'était pas de la
philosophie
parce que le propre du pragmatisme c'est
justement de remettre en cause
radicalement les fondements
intellectuels les fondements conceptuels
sur lesquels on a coutume de bâtir une
pensée philosophique
et d'ailleurs james le précise dès le
début de son ouvrage dans sa première
leçon sur le pragmatisme
il nous dit que le pragmatisme ne
désigne pas tant un système de pensée
philosophique ne désigne pas tant une
doctrine le pragmatisme désigne une
attitude si vous préférez le pragmatisme
ne vous dis pas ce que vous devez penser
le pragmatisme ne vous indique pas la
vérité le pragmatisme vous indique
comment il vous est possible de vous
comporter intellectuellement face à un
problème
est ce qui définit le pragmatisme le
seul et unique critère d'appréciation
que le pragmatisme reconnaît comme
valable c'est celui des implications
pratiques de nos idées
autrement dit pour le pragmatisme ce qui
fait la valeur d'une idée n'est pas son
contenu ce qui fait la valeur d'une idée
ce sont ses implications pratiques
et non pour les pragmatistes une idée
n'a pas de réalité autonome elle est
toujours lié aux conséquences pratiques
qu'elles engendrent
donc c'est ça finalement l'étrangeté du
courant pragmatiste c'est ce déplacement
du critère d'évaluation d'une idée le
pragmatisme ne se préoccupent pas de la
vérité d'une idée et on se penchera tout
à l'heure sur cette question de la
vérité du point de vue pragmatiste le
pragmatisme secret occupe uniquement de
la valeur pratique d'une idée
alors évidemment en vous disant ça j'ai
bien conscience qu'une partie d'entre
vous va bondir de son siège en se disant
mais enfin qu'est ce que c'est que cette
philosophie qui évalue une idée par
rapport à ses conséquences pratiques
qu'est ce que ça veut dire parce que si
on va au bout de ce raisonnement
ça veut dire qu'une chose est vraie à
partir du moment où elle a des
conséquences avantageuses donc
finalement c'est la réduction de la
penser à l'intérêt et ça c'est la
négation même de l'esprit philosophique
l'esprit philosophique qui depuis
socrate nous enseigne que la recherche
de la vérité doit être totalement
désintéressé et que la vérité elle est
bonne en soi elle est bonne parce
qu'elle est la vérité et non pas parce
qu'elle engendre des conséquences
favorables
le combat de socrate contre les
sophistes c'était précisément le combat
contre la philosophie considéré comme un
instrument à l'instrument du pouvoir
un instrument la persuasion un
instrument l'intérêt
la philosophie n'at-elle pas une mission
plus noble la philosophie n'avait pas
vocation à se détacher des intérêts
matériels
qu'est ce que c'est que ce pragmatisme
qui nous dit que la valeur d'une idée
est lié à ses conséquences pratiques
et puis surtout cette conception de la
philosophie mme elle ouvre sur le
relativisme le plus total
parce que si la valeur d'une idée se
mesure à ses conséquences pratiques là
qui décide que la conséquence pratique
est positive ou négative qui décide
qu'une idée a un intérêt pratique ou pas
l'évaluation des conséquences pratiques
d'une idée va toujours dépendre d'un
point de vue va toujours dépendre d'un
certain critère est par définition un
critère est toujours arbitraire
dire qu'une idée n'a de valeur que par
rapport à ses conséquences pratiques est
ce que ce n'est pas renoncer à toute
espèce de vérité
bien c'est ce qu'on va voir maintenant
ce que nous dit william james c'est que
si deux idées n'entraîne pas de
différence dans la pratique
alors elles sont en réalité équivalente
et la réciproque de cette proposition
c'est que si deux idées identique
conduisent à des conséquences pratiques
différentes
alors elles ne sont pas identiques
retenez bien ça pour le pragmatisme si
deux propositions n'entraîne aucune
différence dans la pratique
alors elles sont équivalentes
vous aider à bien comprendre cette idée
je vais vous lire un passage de la
première leçon de william james dans son
livre le pragmatisme
je cite la méthode pragmatique est avant
tout une méthode de résolution des
débats métaphysique qui sans cela
seraient interminable le monde est il un
ou multiple est il soumis à la fatalité
ou bien est il libre est-il matériel ou
spirituelle chacune de ces notions et
plus ou moins valables pour rendre
compte de l'univers et donne lieu à des
discussions interminables en
l'occurrence la méthode pragmatique vise
à interpréter chaque notion en fonction
de ses conséquences pratiques
quelle différence y aurait-il en
pratique si telle notion plutôt que tel
autre était vrai si aucune différence
pratique n'apparaît c'est que les deux
notions sont pratiquement équivalente et
que la discussion est vaine il ne
saurait y avoir de différence qu'ils ne
fassent de différence autres par la
philosophie ne devrait avoir pour unique
fonction que de déterminer précisément
quelle différence cela fera pour vous ou
pour moi at elle était le moment de
notre vie si l'on tient pour vrai telle
formule de l'univers plutôt que tel
autre
alors comme je sais que vous serez
nombreux à français les sourcils
face à cette conception pragmatiste de
la philosophie mme je vais tout de suite
vous donner un exemple très concret
imaginons deux personnes qui affirment
toutes les deux croire dans l'existence
de dieu donc la première personne
affirme dieu existe et la deuxième
personne affirme également dieu existe
si on s'en tient à une approche
philosophique classique en irak ces deux
propositions sont équivalentes mais un
pragmatiste voudra aller plus loin il
faudra comprendre quelles sont les
implications pratiques pour chacune des
deux personnes de leur croyance en dieu
et donc il demandera à la première
personne qu est-ce qu implique dans les
faits la croyance en dieu qu'est ce que
le fait de croire en l'existence de dieu
a comme conséquence pratique
à ce moment là la personne lui répondra
bien pour moi ça signifie qu'il existe
au dessus du monde terrestre un être
tout puissant et omniscient qui nous
prescrit d'agir
d'une certaine manière qui nous commande
de faire le bien et qui nous jugera à
notre mort
autrement dit ma croyance en l'existence
de dieu a pour conséquence pratique que
je dois suivre la voie du bien
maintenant imaginons que la deuxième
personne nous disent dieu existe mais
pour moi dieu ne nous jugent pas dieu a
créé l'univers
mais dieu ne nous prescrit rien en terme
d'action c'est la vision des listes de
dieu conçu comme grand architecte cette
idée d'une force créatrice et
organisatrice de l'univers mais qui n'a
pas vocation à nous dire ce qu'est le
bien ou ce qu'est le mal
selon cette conception de dieu les
cultes religieux les rituels religieux
sont des inventions humaines qui
n'émanent pas directement de la volonté
divine
d'ailleurs les des listes se montrent
généralement assez critique envers les
religions
il considère davantage comme des
systèmes politiques que comme des
médiations vers l'être suprême
donc sans aller plus loin dans le détail
de cette conception je pense que vous
aurez compris l'idée c'est de dire que
la proposition dieu existe ne nous dit
rien tant qu'on en n'a pas développé les
conséquences dans la pratique
affirmer notre croyance en dieu ne nous
apprend rien tant que l'on n'a pas
explicité ce qu'impliquait concrètement
notre croyance en dieu
pour james une proposition et non
pertinente quand elle ne permet pas de
comprendre ce que l'on veut dire par là
quand on dit que dieu existe qu'est ce
qu'on veut dire par là
qu'est ce que ça implique qu'est ce que
ça signifie concrètement
sssa l'attitude du pragmatiste face à
n'importe quel énoncés c'est qu'une fois
que l'énoncé a été formulée le
pragmatiste très bon et donc quelles
différences à fait dans la pratique
et si de propositions différentes
n'induisent aucune différence dans la
pratique si on est incapable de répondre
à cette question quelle différence a
fait alors ça signifie que les deux
propositions sont équivalentes
ça signifie qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
débattre et de se disputer au tour de
deux propositions qui n'implique aucune
différence deux idées différentes
doivent conduire à des conséquences
différentes et si ce n'est pas le cas
alors elles ne sont pas différentes
et donc ça pour le pragmatiste c'est
extrêmement important
c'est même totalement crucial parce que
ça permet de résoudre un débat qui ne
pourraient pas être résolu si on se
limite est simplement à l'énoncé des
deux propositions
deux personnes peuvent affirmer que dieu
existe et se trouvait davantage en
désaccord qu'une personne qui
affirmerait que dieu existe
vis-à-vis d'une autre qui affirmerait
que dieu n'existe pas vous comprenez si
le fait que deux personnes affirme que
dieu existe mais que cette affirmation
n'entraîne pas les mêmes conséquences
dans la pratique
à ce moment là il devient totalement
illégitime de dire qu'elle pense la même
chose
il devient totalement illégitime de dire
que leur pensée est la même la pensée
n'est pas la même puisque leurs pensées
n'applique pas les mêmes conséquences
et donc si on a aimé l'idée que les
mêmes causes produisent les mêmes effets
si on n'obtient pas les mêmes effets
c'est qu'on n'avait pas les mêmes causes
si on n'a pas les mêmes conséquences
dans la pratique c'est que l'idée
n'était pas la même parce que maintenant
imaginons une personne qui dirait dieu
existe mais dieu ne me demande rien dieu
ne me prescrit pas d'agir de telle ou
telle manière et bien qu est-ce qui va
distinguer cette croyance qu est-ce qui
va distinguer cette idée de l'idée selon
laquelle dieu n'existe pas
quelle différence dans la pratique va
entraîner ces deux propositions
différentes bien la réponse de james est
toute trouvée
si deux idées n'entraîne aucune
différence dans la pratique
alors elles sont équivalentes
autrement dit il est possible d'affirmer
que la croyance en dieu et la non
croyance en dieu que le déisme et
l'athéisme sont en réalité deux idées
équivalente
alors là je sais que certains d'entre
vous ne vont pas être contents ils vont
pas être contents parce qu'ils vont dire
mais c'est absurde
quel culot faut-il avoir pour affirmer
que le déisme et l'athéisme serait en
fait deux idées équivalente
ça n'a pas de sens
eh bien ça n'a pas de sens pour peu
qu'on arrive à dégager une différence
dans la pratique
parce qu'aussi longtemps qu'on trouvera
aucune différence dans la pratique
effectivement il paraît difficile de
démontrer que ces deux idées sont
différentes
alors évidemment dire qu'il n'ya aucune
différence dans la pratique entre deux
idées différentes
ça reste à prouver ce que je veux dire
c'est que reprendre l'exemple du déiste
et de la t il est tout à fait possible
de trouver des différences dans la
pratique par exemple il est possible que
la croyance en dieu du déiste le
conduisent à une certaine forme
d'optimisme en se disant qu'après tout
même si dieu ne nous prescrit rien sa
présence nous rassure sa présence nous
réconforte
se dire que dieu existe et qu'il est le
créateur de notre univers ça répond
aussi à la question notre origine et en
répondant ainsi à la question notre
origine
cela apaise l'une de nos angoisses
l'angoissent de l'ignorance l'angoissent
du non sens
croire en dieu ça donne du sens
vous voyez lorsqu'on dit qu'il n'ya pas
de différence dans la pratique
en réalité on trouve toujours des
différences
est ce que nous disent les pragmatistes
c'est que ce sont précisément ces
différences qui doivent être prises en
compte lorsqu'on évalue et lorsqu'on se
positionne en faveur d'une idée
l'idée n'a pas de valeur de par sa
formulation elle n'a pas de valeur en
tant qu entité abstraite indépendante du
monde matériel
la valeur d'une idée est toujours
fonction de ses conséquences dans la
pratique
alors avant d'aller plus loin et
d'expliciter la conception qu'ont les
pragmatistes de l'idée j'aimerais tenter
de vous expliquer en quoi la conception
pragmatiste de william james apparaît
comme profondément original j'oserais
même dire comme révolutionnaire dans
l'histoire des idées dans l'histoire de
la philosophie
dans son livre le pragmatisme james part
du constat qu'il existe deux tendances
au sein de l'histoire de la philosophie
de tendance qui se sont affrontés et que
le pragmatisme prétend réconcilier
ces deux tendances c'est le rationalisme
et l'empirisme
donc là il faut que je rappelle
rapidement ce qu'on appelle le
rationalisme et l'empirisme le
rationalisme c'est la conception
philosophique qui placent au dessus de
tout l'existence de principes immuables
des principes immuables dont la réalité
matérielle ne serait que la traduction
autrement dit pour le rationaliste la
réalité matérielle n'a pas d'existence
propre elle n'a pas d'autonomie
ontologique
elle est le produit de loi transcendante
qui trône au dessus du monde
c'est la vision qu'on trouve chez
descartes des cartes qui dans son
discours de la méthode nous enjoint de
nous défier et de nous méfier de nos
perceptions pour des cartes on n'accepte
pas la vérité par l'observation du monde
sensible
on n'accède pas à la vérité par
l'expérience et la sensation on accède à
la vérité par la raison une raison seul
capable de nous faire accéder aux
vérités immuables
al'inverse l'empirisme c'est la
conception philosophique qui fait de la
matière
notre seule source de connaissance
possible l'empirisme c'est l'attitude
qui consiste à fonder la connaissance
sur l'observation l'observation des
faits est d'ailleurs nos méthodes
scientifiques actuelles sont très
largement inspiré de l'empirisme
c'est-à-dire de l'idée que c'est
l'expérimentation qui peut nous
permettre de déduire les lois qui
gouvernent notre monde physique donc
pour schématiser le rationaliste par des
principes pour descendre vers les faits
il part du général pour descendre vers
le particulier tandis qu lampiris tu
pars des faits pour remonter vers les
principes il part des cas particuliers
pour remonter vers la généralité
et ce qui est intéressant de noter c'est
que james identifient ces deux
conceptions du monde
ces deux superpuissances conceptuel qui
se sont affrontées toute l'histoire à
deux tempéraments
pour lui le rationalisme et l'empirisme
désigne d'abord des tempéraments
et par tempérament il faut entendre
sensibilité il faut entendre deux modes
de perception du monde
les modes de perception parfaitement
indépendant de leur validité objective
c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que pour james nous conception du
monde n'a rien à voir avec sa validité
objective elle a toujours des
ramifications dans le tempérament pour
le dire autrement notre tempérament
n'est pas le résultat de notre pensée
c'est notre pensée qui est le résultat
de notre tempérament
nous avons les idées de notre
sensibilité saissac nous dit james
sensibilité
et donc pour james ce qui caractérise le
tempérament rationaliste c'est
l'admiration pour l'idéal
l'idéal c'est à dire le bur ce qui n'est
pas souillé par la matière
ce qui est éternel
alors que ce qui va caractériser le
tempérament empiriste c'est une forme de
pessimisme et de désenchantement ce que
james appelle un tempérament endurcis
lampiris tu sais celui qui ne se fait
pas d'illusion sur le monde c'est celui
qui s'en tient à la stricte matérialité
du monde et qui ne va pas chercher au
delà du monde
un principe unificateur là où le
rationaliste et très attachée au
principe unificateur
d'ailleurs james le formule 1 si il dit
que le rationaliste est un moniste c'est
à dire quelqu'un qui est à la recherche
de l'unité l'unité fondamentale l'unité
originel là-haut lampiris tu es d'un
pluraliste c'est à dire quelqu'un qui va
considérer les parties avant le tout
pour l' empire east ce sont les partis
qui constituent le tout alors que pour
le rationaliste c'est le to qui est à
l'origine des parties
goyer qu'on a bien affaire à deux
conceptions du monde différente qui
selon james sont les conséquences de
deux sensibilités et se trouve que james
et en psychologue
il n'est pas étonnant que pour lui une
conception philosophique soit d'abord
une affaire psychologique une conception
philosophique c'est une production de
l'esprit
donc la conclusion qu'en tire james sait
qu'une vérité est tojours partie
prenante d'un contexte matériel aucune
vérité n'est jamais un absolu
et même si vous estimez qu'il existe des
vérités qui sont au-delà de tout
contexte
au delà de toute circonstance bien des
maux répondra que ce n'est pas vrai et
que ce qu'on appelle des vérités
absolues et vérité transcendante et
universelles sont toujours des vérités
du point de vue de l'esprit qui les
formulent sont toujours des vérités du
point de vue des conditions humaines de
leur production
affirmer que la terre tourne autour du
soleil ce n'est pas une vérité
universelle non pas au sens où ce serait
faux bien sûr que la terre tourne autour
du soleil
mais ces contes etc soit dans la mesure
où ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
moment du big bang la terre ne tournait
pas autour du soleil par définition
herlem dire oui mais là on chipote non
on chipote pas ont des absolus tease le
concept de vérité
ramène le concept de vérité à ces
conditions humaines de production
et en faisant ça on montre et on
illustre le fait que toute idée est
tributaire d'un contexte d'énonciation
et d'ailleurs vous aurez remarqué que
quand on dit la terre tourne autour du
soleil
on emploie ce qu'on appelle le présent
de vérité générale et cet amusant qu'on
ait besoin de préciser vérité générale
parce que par définition une vérité est
supposé être général on parlait de
vérité générale c'est comme être un
pléonasme
et bien pour william james une vérité
générale
ce n'est pas une vérité absolue
parce qu'une vérité absolue nous est par
définition inaccessible elle nous est
inaccessible parce que nous ne sommes
pas des êtres absolue nous ne sommes pas
des êtres qui ont la capacité de se
hisser à l'absolu
nous sommes des êtres soumis à des
contraintes matérielles à des
contraintes naturelles et donc à des
contraintes intellectuelles et
cognitives qui sont directement liés à
ces contraintes matérielles
l'esprit humain et matériellement
contraint
[Musique]
et parce qu'il est matériellement
contraint toute prétention à une
quelconque vérité absolue est une
prétention à laquelle il est incapable
de satisfaire
et d'ailleurs une bonne manière de
mettre en évidence le fait que toute
prétention à la vérité absolue relève du
mix et de l'illusion
c'est le simple fait que toute vérité se
formule dans un langage
toute vérité passe par le prisme d'un
langage
or le langage est bien une création
humaine le langage est une création
culturelle
c'est un artefact qui est liée à un
contexte et à des conditions matérielles
d'apparition et qui à ce titre ne peut
pas prétendre nous mettre en contact
avec l'absolu
selon james toute prétention humaine à
l'absolu est vaine
et parce qu'elle est vaine il faut
ramener l'idée à sa réalité matérielle à
ce qu'elle est fondamentalement une
croyance
pour les pragmatistes toute idée est une
si on se rapproche de ce qu'on avait vu
chez bergson sur le rôle fonctionnel de
la pensée
le rôle fonctionnel de la pensée ça
consiste à dire que la pensée n'est
qu'une manière de découper la réalité
manière de concevoir la réalité à
travers une grille de lecture pour
pouvoir mieux la maîtriser et ainsi agir
en conséquence
bergson nous disaient les idées sont des
étiquettes qu'on colle sur les choses
mais les idées ne sont pas la réalité
les idées sont notre représentation de
la réalité
et de la même façon que les mots sont
une convention entre les êtres humains
pour communiquer à propos de la réalité
les idées sont des conventions
intellectuelle qui permettent de se
représenter le monde pour mieux agir
pour le pragmatisme la finalité d'une
idée la raison d'être d'une idée c'est
l'action
pour bien comprendre la pensée
pragmatiste il est indispensable de
comprendre la définition pragmatiste de
la vérité une vérité est une idée qui
fonctionne dans la pratique qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'une
vérité celle énoncée d'une relation
fonctionnelle qui permet d'unifier les
faits pratique
et c'est ce qui conduit james affirmé
cette chose absolument scandaleuse d'un
point de vue philosophique qui est
qu'une idée est vrai quand elle est
bonne bonne pourquoi bonne pour l'action
bonne pour l'adaptation à la réalité
parce que toutes nos idées tirent leurs
origines d'un contexte matériel et d'un
rapport à la réalité matérielle
ça signifie qu'une idée est vrai quand
elle est pratiquement valable
une idée est vrai quand elle fonctionne
et c'est ce qui conduit james à dire que
la vérité d'une idée n'est pas quelque
chose que l'on peut établir de manière
définitive une chose n'est pas vrai une
fois pour toutes
elle est vrai dans la mesure où elle
supporte le test de la vérification
pratique
une vérité n'est jamais immuable une
vérité est toujours lié à un contexte
d'énonciation particulier et donc une
idée reste vrai dans la mesure où elles
se vérifient dans nos actions
donc vous voyez que pour les
pragmatistes une idée n'est jamais vrai
de manière absolue elle n'est vrai que
dans le contexte local de sa
vérification
et parce que le réel émouvant parce que
le réel échange en vient à la conclusion
c'est qu'il ne faut pas hésiter à
remplacer une croyance par une autre
lorsque notre croyance ne se vérifie
plus
lorsque notre croyance ne passe plus le
test de la vérification pratique
et d'ailleurs vous aurez remarqué que
dans notre vie de tous les jours c'est
souvent lorsque nos croyances se
heurtent à des murs c'est souvent
lorsque nos croyances sont contredites
par la réalité contredite par les faits
que l'on ait poussé à s'en défaire mais
tant que nos croyances fonctionne tant
que nos croyances nous permettent de
bien vivre de vivre sans subir la
réponse contradictoires du réel et à ce
moment là on a aucune raison d'en
changer
on n'a aucune raison de remplacer une
croyance par une autre tant que notre
croyance n'a pas subi la pression
contradictoires des faits
le principe même de la remise en cause
de la remise en question d'une de nos
croyances
c'est le fait qu'une de nos croyances
nous a conduit à un problème nous a
conduit à une contradiction nous a
conduit à un échec
c'est seulement quand on constate
l'échec de l'une de nos croyances à
fonctionner dans la pratique que l'on
est amené à remettre en cause cette
croyance
alors pas systématiquement on peut
s'obstiner dans une croyance qui ne
fonctionne pas ça s'appelle l'entêtement
et james explique justement très
précisément en quoi nous passons tout
notre temps à composer avec nos
croyances
parce qu'à chaque fois que l'une de nos
croyances est réfutée par l'expérience
c'est tout l'édifice de nos vérités
individuelles qui menace de s'effondrer
donc la tentation est grande de
préserver l'équilibré général de
l'édifice en fermant les yeux sur nos
croyances non fonctionnel
dès lors qu'une expérience compromet la
stabilité de notre système intellectuel
notre réflexe premier c'est de rejeter
cette expérience
c'est de la nier c'est de fermer les
yeux parce qu'alors on se sent menacé
on se sent en danger
ce estimé notre besoin de cohérence
intellectuelle parce que dès lors qu'on
prend conscience d'une contradiction au
sein de nos croyances
c'est comme si une difficile
apparaissait
et ça psychologiquement c'est très
difficile à supporter
le besoin d'unité de cohérence
intellectuelle est fondamental dans
l'équilibré psychique
et c'est très difficile de supporter
l'incohérence c'est très difficile de
supporter la dissonance
sion de la valeur fonctionnelle de nos
croyances je vais vous lire un passage
de la 6ème leçon de william james qui
porte sur la conception pragmatiste de
la vérité je cite en premier lieu et
selon le sens commun la vérité d'un état
mental désigne cette fonction qui
consiste à nous guider de manière
valable
lorsqu un moment de notre expérience
quel qu'il soit nous inspire une pensée
vrai cela signifie que tôt ou tard
guidé par l nous plongeons à nouveau
dans les faits de l'expérience pour
établir avec eux des relations
profitables
malheur à celui dont les croyances ne
tiennent pas compte de l'ordre dans
lequel les réalités de son expérience se
succèdent l2 le mèneront nulle part où
l'induire en erreur
l'idée qui est ici développé c'est que
la vérité désigne essentiellement ce
processus par lequel une croyance se
vérifie dans notre expérience et parce
que nous avons tendance à absolutiser
nos croyances
autrement dit parce que nous avons
tendance à spontanément identifier nos
croyances
à la vérité il nous est parfois très
difficile d'accepter que notre croyance
n'était que notre croyance
et c'est finalement notre penchant
rationaliste c'est à dire notre penchant
à préférer les vérités immuables et
définitive qui rend particulièrement
difficile psychologiquement
le constat de l'échec de nos croyances
il est d'autant plus difficile
d'abandonner une croyance que l'on a la
conviction que cette croyance est la
vérité
donc on peut s'obstiner dans une
croyance qui ne fonctionne pas une
croyance démentie par notre expérience
ne pourra jamais faire en sorte que la
réalité nous donne raison
quand elle nous a donné tort
et si la réalité bouscule nos croyances
si la réalité
mais à l'épreuve nos croyances voir les
anéantit il devient alors nécessaire de
les abandonner
car comme tout ce qui existe sur terre
elles auront fait leur temps
particularité du pragmatisme c'est
d'intégrer cette dimension psychologique
de notre rapport à la vérité
c'est d'intégrer le fait que nos
croyances sont bien souvent pour nous un
moyen de maintenir la cohésion générale
de notre système de pensée
et que lorsqu'une pièce du puzzle ne
s'insère pas avec les autres
autrement dit lorsqu'une idée issue
d'une nouvelle expérience ne s'intègre
pas dans le puzzle de nos croyances
lorsqu'une croyants se heurte au démenti
de l'expérience vient on ne va pas
accueillir cette nouvelle croyance
on ne va pas accueillir la vérité de
cette expérience nouvelle
on va détourner le regard
on va faire comme si on n'avait pas vu
sartre disait bien que si le garçon de
café réfléchit à sa condition et s'il
s'aperçoit qu'à tout moment il peut
jeter son tablier pour vivre
l'expérience de la liberté radical cette
idée va l'angoissé
parce que cette idée menace l'équilibré
général de ses croyances
elles menacent son système d'auto
représentation
elles menacent son image de lui-même
si on pragmatiste de la vérité nous
dérange c'est parce qu'elle va à
l'encontre de notre tendance à vouloir
tout systématisée
à vouloir tout unifié meu et à vouloir
contempler le tableau cohérent et
homogène de nos idées
or nos idées ne sont pas un tableau
cohérent
nos idées sont un magma
et sinon refusons cette perspective si
nous refusons qu'il y ait des
irrégularités dans le puzzle de nos
idées nous nous condamnons à la
souffrance
si le but de la pensée c'est de
comprendre le monde pour s'y adapter
si le monde évolue sans cesse alors nos
idées également évolueront sans cesse
est ce que pour autant cela fait de nous
des esprits inachevé
oui
nous sommes tous des esprits inachevé
c'est pour cette raison que nous sommes
capables d'évoluer
d'apprendre de devenir meilleur je vous
remercie
[Musique]